[Musique]
oh
j'y arrivais pas non j'y arrivais pas
qu'est-ce que je fais là je détestais en
public vous être parent je suis là et
ils sont là et ils attendent que je dise
quelque chose j'ai oublié mon texte
chez les mains moites
le gars qui est prêt à exploser la gorge
nouée dix écoliers beaucoup trop serré
cette censure aussi d'ailleurs
et cette lumière en trop forte bien que
moi qui entoure ce bruit de l'aqim un
peu trop porte sud ailleurs et cette
voix dans ma tête qui me dit tu es trop
nuls et il n'y arrivera jamais
excusez moi je vous ai des secrets
seconde dans ma tête dans mes pensées et
un peu le bazar jallère folle mais je ne
suis pas folle du moins pas beaucoup je
suis hyper sensible aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous parler de ça de mon
hypersensibilité nom de
l'hypersensibilité alors beaucoup de
gens ne savent pas ce que c'est pourtant
vous êtes à peu près 100 dans la salle
aujourd'hui et selon les statistiques
vous êtes entre 15 à 20 personnes à être
hyper sensible autant d'hommes que de
femmes
ça peut être étonnant non alors
j'aimerais préciser que l'hyper
sensibilité c'est quelque chose de
génétique il faut pas chercher à la
soigner ou à la supprimer on est comme
ça c'est une part de nous c'est quoi
être hyper sensible être hyper sensible
se voir se sentir ressentir les choses
un peu différemment les choses plus
intensément
en fait c'est percevoir des détails que
les autres ne voient pas c'est c'est
beaucoup en fait on ont réagi de manière
excessive à des stimulations les
stimulations externes comme notre
environnement
le bruit les lumières les sons les
odeurs les gens et des stimulations
interne c'est-à-dire nos propres
émotions et nos propres sensations
pourquoi on réagit comme ça tout
simplement parce que notre cerveau
travaille de façon un peu différente
en fait il traite beaucoup plus
d'informations beaucoup plus vite et
beaucoup plus longtemps et beaucoup plus
en profondeur ce qui peut être vite
fatigante stressant voire déprimant
du coup être hyper sensible peut
apparaître comme un handicap quand on
demande quel est mon plus grand défaut
je réponds mon hypersensibilité
quand on me demande quelle est ma plus
grande qualité je réponds aussi mon
hypersensibilité ehs aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous donner quatre étapes qui
peuvent vous aider à mieux vivre
la première la prise de conscience alors
vous sentez différents incompris vous
avez l'impression de vivre dans une
montagnes russes émotionnelles c'est à
dire que quand vous êtes mal vous êtes
vraiment très mal mais quand vous êtes
bien c'est le pur bonheur
vous êtes très sensibles à votre
environnement vous avez un manque de
confiance en vous bon vous êtes sûrement
hypersensible mais je pense que vous le
savez déjà
alors ne cherchez pas s'il vous plaît à
vouloir être comme tout le monde parce
que vous ne pouvez pas
ce qui m'amène à la deuxième étape cedex
et son hypersensibilité souvent on va
chercher à cacher cette part du nom ne
peut pas cacher ce clown et pourquoi on
fait ça parce qu'on voit que les mauvais
côtés
mais vous savez être hyper sensible
c'est aussi de nombreuses qualités
telles que l'empathie avoir cette
capacité d' écoute se mettre à la place
de l'autre les d être intuitif à force
d'avoir tous nos sens développé sur
développer on a fini par développer un
sixième sens être créatif on arrive à
avoir le beau et à le créer la passion
comme quand l' hyper sensible entreprend
quelque chose qu'ils aiment réellement
réellement il met tout son coeur et
toute son âme et il va jusqu'au bout
créer un monde meilleur
là moi je considère mon père sensibilité
comme un super pouvoir
j'ai rebaptisé mon hypersensibilité
super sensibilité mais comme tout
pouvoir
il est important à contrôler pour éviter
que celui-ci prenne le contrôle sur ce
qui m'amène à la troisième étape
maîtriser son hypersensibilité
imaginez une éponge celle ci absorbent
si on les sort pas elle sera beaucoup
trop plein d'eau de bactéries tout ce
que vous voulez
les hyper sensible c'est exactement
pareil nous sommes d éponge qui absorbe
ou les énergies les émotions des gens on
se retrouve alors vite submergé il est
important de laisser évacuer ses
émotions
les personnes
il a besoin de se retrouver seuls de
s'isoler d'être au calme pour se
connaître lui même et reconnaître ses
émotions afin de les laisser s'exprimer
l'art est un très bon moyen d'expression
pour les pertes sensibles alors ça peut
être l'écriture la photographie la
musique la peinture peu importe trouver
ce qu'il vous plaît
le sommeil mes amis se moquent souvent
de moi quand je leur dis que j'ai besoin
entre 8 à 10 heures de sommeil par nuit
mais c'est vrai c'est ça a été trouvé
les personnes qui bat réellement double
besoin de plus de sommeil que la
majorité des personnes alors dormi
savourait aussi est important
d'apprendre à gérer son stress évacuer
son stress fait du sport de la
méditation et aussi comme je les dis
nous absorbons les énergies il est donc
important de s'entourer de personnes
positif et d'aller dans des
environnements là où il ya de belles
énergies tels que la nature par exemple
afin de se ressourcer de se recentrer
sur soi même et de se reconnecter route
alors bien sûr ce n'est pas un travail
facile
c'est un travail de tous les jours mais
ça vaut réellement luxe
dernière étape c'est tout simplement de
s'aimer arrêtez d'être si durs envers
vous même soyez bout envers vous même
soyez bienveillant et aimez vous on est
tous sensibles à différents degrés est
pour beaucoup d'entre nous la
sensibilité rime avec fragilité surtout
dans les pays occidentaux mais c'est
faux
c'est un signe d'humanité en fait c'est
ce qui fait la nature de l'homme nous
serons de simples corps des robots des
machines alors n'ayez pas peur d'offrir
votre sensibilité au monde ne la
cacherai pas légal a gardé pas pour vous
partagez la pour finir j'aimerais vous
offrir une chanson que j'ai écrite
spécialement pour aujourd'hui
voilà
a écrit haïti
espace web avec un homme est mort
[Musique]
marine c'est que les achats de cadeaux
utiles et la baisse des loyers de la
[Musique]
démo
à
[Musique]
la yamaha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]